[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
hello
hey we told you we were coming back
welcome to this special edition of fat
man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard hey
hi
so the other day i got to do an
interview with uh james gunn
uh i did a review of uh of uh peacemaker
his amazing new show on hbo max which i
absolutely [ __ ] love
um
uh i got to interview james and and uh
they cut it into this video that they
put out which is really great
but i you know james the interview
portion in that video is only about five
minutes when uh dr josh roush shot the
interview
the the night that we shot it
um i talked to james for like a half an
hour and it was about like deep cuts
comic book stuff
uh snyder verse stuff
um writing uh
just he's such a wonderful storyteller
he's got a big heart and stuff
so uh i i asked him when we were all
done i was like hey can we
like throw and they're only going to use
like five minutes of our chat can i
throw the rest of it up on fat man
beyond and he was like oh man go for it
he's i was like there ain't nothing you
want me to pull out he goes not at all
so
it was a fun discussion it's
you know half an hour and i only wish it
was longer and stuff but
it's
interesting as [ __ ] and and he's just
pure joy um
at the height
of his [ __ ] jedi powers right now
so um we got it for you
here uh they were going to put it on the
show last night when we did fat man
beyond which you can go watch right now
uh last night's episode or
we decided it'd probably be better to
give it its own
standalone thing man so
this is me and mark
welcoming you and introducing you
to a
30-minute interview
with uh the only loaded gun i want in my
house ladies and gentlemen ah nice nice
wordplay thank you very much
um
a man uh right at the [ __ ]
the sweet spot he's he's doing the
lord's work and he's he's [ __ ] he's
the bridge
uh between two comic book universes um
he's talented as [ __ ] and peacemaker on
hbo max which drops every [ __ ]
thursday watch episode four right now uh
the first four episodes
uh is an absolute revelation um so
without further ado let's talk to the to
the mind behind it man gentlemen
james gunn ladies and gentlemen i can't
wait
mr gone loaded gun excellent to speak to
you sir how are you i'm good i'm really
good you know it's been a an insane week
for me with uh between shooting and
trying to release the show and
everything else so but i feel good
um the incredible first world problems
that you enjoy
of uh making a massive wonderful new
mill a movie while releasing
a massive new wonderful tv show based on
masterful wonderful movie a massive
wonderful movie that you just did
last year your busy cat my friend and
rightfully very busy yeah let's talk
about where peacemaker comes from i
absolutely love the show when i first uh
saw the trailer when i first heard there
was going to spin off i was like oh that
makes sense he's cool
fun character you can go places with it
uh when i saw the trailer i was like oh
i can't wait superheroes cursing like uh
i was almost cursing myself for like why
didn't i do this
um then i saw the show
and once again what what you do insanely
well is give us the populist
entertainment that puts us in the seats
and then you sneak
a wonderful human story with a soul and
emotion under it and i did not suspect
that that's what we were going to be
having with peacemaker i thought it
would just be a fun romp and it remains
a fun romp but you are having your cake
and eating it too at the same time with
this story man uh it is
next level work you're always a
fantastic writer and a a clever one at
the very least
but this there's something coming out in
this work man that like
it seems a little bit deeper and closer
to home than we've even seen before
where's it coming from
well i mean i think it was a couple of
things i think number one i just really
wanted to work with john
but number two
a lot of the stuff i've dealt with is
are sort of these fables like guardians
is a fable about childhood trauma that
takes place in outer space
it's very emotional but it's also it's
an outer space we don't have to deal
with real humans uh but peacemaker has a
little bit to do a little bit more to do
with you know society today what's going
on in our world what are the kind of
people that are you know in our world
and so
dealing with that social stuff a little
bit more i felt like peacemaker was a
character who gave me an opportunity to
deal with that and giving me the
opportunity also to deal with the
character of leo adebayo who's played by
danielle brooks and the fact that two of
them have this sort of
you know beautiful friendship that they
find because it's based
strictly on their love or their
like for each other as human beings and
um and i thought that that was an
interesting dynamic and maybe something
that we should talk a little bit more
about about how people with very very
different belief systems can actually
like each other and i have people in my
own life that are like that people who
you know believe very differently than i
do about politics about this about
whatever and and instead of
being a person that screams at people
thinking that that somehow is going to
change their mind
um
you know can see somebody else's
humanity despite their different beliefs
that's what really is on display when
you watch the show um you know there's a
cartoony level of violence and fun but
it's got this incredibly human
uh heart and soul um
i as i watched
the first episode and then went straight
into the next three because the hbo max
dropped all the first three episodes at
once
uh my impression i got
or let me let me ask you
when you went into suicide squad were
you thinking
peacemaker series at all it occurs to me
as like you're working with an actor
who's so talented that you're like
this is a versatile action figure that i
could do a lot of things with he's fun
and he also knows how to play
heart and warmth and stuff like and plus
the character being larger than life
you know you get to play with the
archetypes of superheroes while playing
with a classic superhero not even one
that you had to create yourself so you
can break down
which was it chicken or the egg how did
we get to peacemaker uh the egg i guess
that means it was it was definitely john
cena i mean it was
wanting to work with john again because
listen this was you know
the beginning of cobin when i decided to
do this i was lonely john and i get
along extraordinarily well i thought
he'd be a fun guy to make a tv show with
i trust him with my life he's a truly
good
uh individual with a lot of integrity
but i also thought you know i saw
glimpses of what john was capable of it
uh peacemaker we talked a lot about who
this guy was where he came from how he
felt awkward when he's around everybody
else what his dad was like you know all
of these things we talked about with
with john and then i saw glimpses of
what john was able to do emotionally or
dramatically that we didn't really get
to deal with you know when we see
the big moment in suicide squad without
giving a major spoiler away which
anybody these peacemakers gonna be
spoiled you know there's this humanity
in john that he brings to it and i
wanted to deal with that i thought that
is a seed for a whole
you know a whole television series
really
um so
it's the humanity that you kind of saw
on the character that made you go like i
want to dig deeper i want to play with
that further because that is a really
wonderful scene in suicide squad it's
got power to it and john up until that
point in the movie is is
playing a cartoon and then suddenly you
see the human being underneath um it's
so awesome to hear that you saw that and
you were like i want to play
deeper with that now you brought the
team with you as well like
in in terms of the the support team
jen uh steve uh so forth and so on yeah
is that a moment that's born too while
you're making the movie going like i
could bring these cats with me no i
think i started thinking about the
peacemaker show like you know since
you know i didn't really i thought a
little bit about it uh but then i
thought about it more consistent more
i thought about it a lot more while i
was edited
and then when warner brothers came to me
and said hey listen you know you want to
do a tv show you have any characters you
want to spin off and i said yeah
definitely peacemaker um
that after that is when i thought oh
let's put uh kind of most narcotics
let's build up their story let's bring
some of these other characters you know
you know biola as you see you know
kind of you know strengthen some of
those relationships a little bit and
build on that mythology
now a lot of cats would might hear that
and go like wait they came to him and
said what do you want to do what
breathing rarefied breathing air
that he has
tell the folks at home how one gets
to that rarefied breathing air like
you're a trauma kid you began yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah deep deep with lloyd and
stuff like that yeah and yeah and you're
bringing like trauma ideas and the fun
of those movies into
one of the most massive mainstream
markets
on the planet the sensibility
is still there
tell cats how hard it is to get from
that point to this point
well i mean listen it's like i started
working when i was you know
trying to get to this point you know
30 years ago almost and really have
spent i guess more than 30 years ago and
have spent most of my life
trying to be able to do this so it's
it's taken a lot of effort really and a
lot of work and i didn't have my
twenties like other people did because i
sat in my room uh you know all day uh
writing and and uh and watching kevin
smith movies um you definitely are very
cute
so you definitely wrote though and
that's a big part of that story is that
and you know now you live in a world
where you're like uh they're like what
do you want to do and you're like this
is the story i'd like to tell
but you worked in a world for a while
where you were the guy banging out words
for others and happy to do so but was
there always a thought of like look i'll
write for them but one day i'm going to
direct these
i wasn't happy to do so i'm being
completely honest with you it was very
difficult being a screenwriter for me
that is
being a screenwriter by itself is not my
natural inclination it was uncomfortable
i don't i can't my my brother doesn't
he's happy being a screenwriter that's
what he does um
but i'm not i want to direct i feel like
directing is the you know and i'm sure
you relate
directing is the final the final draft
of the script
yeah so turning that over to somebody
else
you know there were really good
situations with it like where you know
donna you know dawn of the dead happened
and zack snyder comes in there's a
kick-ass version then there were you
know good i had good relationships with
a lot of these directors like raja
gosnell from the scooby-doo movies and
all this stuff
but always it's different than what i
intended always you know it's you know
and sometimes it's good and sometimes
it's just a milky version of what i
intended so
um i hated it i hated being
being a screenwriter was good because i
was getting paid but it was a job and it
wasn't the same sort of thing as
directing you know a feature where i'm
putting my whole heart into it and
everything i can
just to show you how it's always like
the grass is always greener and stuff
like i remember the weekend that you had
i think it was what was it both like
dawn of the dead and scooby-doo like
with the number one and two movie or
something like that yeah that's what i
was like yeah yeah yeah i was like this
is like that's like that's it like oh my
god like i was a writer director and i
was still like i wish i was that guy
just writing like the babies for the
majors and stuff and it's so
excellent to hear that you're like look
there was such a hunger that that was
something that i i had to do to get to
where i wanted to be and so yeah
i hadn't even thought about until this
point
that you had written dawn of the dead
and zach
had directed it so you had crossover
going way back in the day what i think
about when i watch peacemaker and
suicide squad
is anybody that was ever like oh the
snyder verse was too dark or whatever
you
you proved validated even like that that
universe works like the suicide squad
and and uh and peacemaker
take place essentially in that that
world and didn't i did i read somewhere
that like you've got did you work with
his stunt coordinator or something like
that too yeah i mean one of the one of
uh
wayne deglish who did the stun
coordination on
um
on peacemaker and i liked him so much
that i brought him to guardians 3 with
me and he's working with heidi money
maker um
but he is uh yeah he was a guy who i
talked to about the gig uh we need a
good stunt coordinator there's a lot of
action in the show and it just gets
bigger and bigger as the show goes on
and i talked to him immediately i liked
the guy and he had worked with zach
before so i talked to zach and asked him
if he was somebody who he thought was
good and zach
sang his praises like to the end of days
about how he's really the best and he
said the biggest problem with wayne is
he sets up stunts and does you know
fight vis with the cameras and that his
crew always has a harder time
doing as good of a job as wayne's fight
viz is originally so right that's that's
where you know that's pretty big uh you
know i mean obviously zack's amazing
with action so that was a pretty big
compliment
the um the the storyline that you're
telling it would have been good enough
if you were just like uh i'm i'm playing
with dc action figures and i'm making
them smash into each other and curse i
was there for that [ __ ] show from the
jump
but the father story that you're telling
is is insanely compelling um we get a
taste of it uh in the first few episodes
particularly in episode two and three
but like four
is where it really
hits hard this week's episode coming up
is like it's where you kind of expose
your heart well first by exposing
peacemaker's heart it's an uncomfortable
scene to watch his father
dress him down so hardcore and the dude
who could like clearly take him out with
a punch
is affected by it that's where you get
that humanity from from john in a
wonderful performance beat i mean of
course he's working opposite robert
who's doing a great job but it's the
receiver of that emotional violence
that that is going to uh kind of uh
telegraph the performance that's going
to make you feel something there um an
amazing scene how deep does that
storyline go is that ron this entire
time around the episode yeah i mean i
think that's one of his prime
relationships in the show is robert the
regular on the show and uh he is uh he's
unrepentant he's a real [ __ ] i mean
there's there's really not i don't know
if i've ever you know
you know i think peter quill his father
is obviously a pretty bad guy ego he
killed his mother with cancer but i
think ego is probably better in some i
mean ego at least liked peter quill he
wanted to work with him but i don't
think you know i think robert patrick
auggie smith he does not like his son
he's got no love for his son and we find
out some reasons for that as the series
goes on but he is a real tough guy and
there isn't much sentiment
sentimentality in who he is and he's a
racist you know he's just a flat-out
racist
and it is i mean that's what to me is
interesting is the idea of like i've
never seen this story told in this
milieu where it's like how do you deal
with people that don't think the same
way you do
it's hard enough when it's like people
you're not related to what if they're
people
that you share blood with that that was
where i was like oh this is where he's
gonna win
awards man um at what as you're writing
it
when does it occur to you how deep you
can go with this like before you even
started or as you're writing you're like
oh i could do this i could do this no i
think i think before i started it i knew
where it was going i knew the general
story and there's a lot of others i mean
i just i'm so excited for people to see
it because it is i i love this the whole
story through episode eight and um
that's what it feels like it feels like
a gigantic movie so far it doesn't feel
episodic it's chapters of a movie
it is it is it's it's one big you know
sixth hour and change story uh about
this guy and about this ensemble really
it is at the end of the day it's an
ensemble it's not only you know
peacemaker it's also vigilante who i
love and after you saw episode four so
you get to see a fantastic scene with
freddie stromo who's just just amazing
in that scene which i've been waiting
for people to see and then you know but
also you know harcourt and and uh and
danielle brooks is leota and
you know chuck woody iwooji is mirn who
is now in guardians 3. steve agee gets
his chance to do some actually dramatic
stuff throughout the series and that's
his first time that he's ever been able
to do that and fight and fight judo
master as well to some degree yeah just
sort of at least poke him and sneak up
behind him but yeah he's uh he gets he
gets he gets uh he doesn't always
he's not the best fighter in the world
but yeah you get a chance to do some
action for sure
uh let me get geeky for a few seconds
did i see an episode four is that bunny
on the dash the bunny that was on rick's
flagship that's right yeah ultra bunny
yeah yeah yeah that's the is that yours
i drew that yeah i drew the shirt so um
that comes from that so we have ultra
bunny i think there's a i can't i think
that yeah there's another scene in which
evan and amber the husband and wife
um evan has it on i think in episode
uh two in the hallway he's got an ultra
bunny t-shirt a different design than
the rick flag so i guess ultra bunny is
a
big cartoon hero he's he's the
in the uh dc eu he's bugs buddy
i smell a backdoor cartoon series coming
my friend very very smart yeah um yeah
the uh the references the side
references to
the larger dc
universe within the the world of of the
dc what do they call the dc extended
universe or cinematic yeah yeah um the
the notion that that might
exist
thrilled me no end the note and that
people know about him or at least he did
and the fact that matter eater lad was
name-checked like the aquaman thing is
funny the wonder woman thing is funny
but like going deep cuts
that's when like as i'm watching the
show i leaned forward all delighted
because i was like i was not expecting
about my [ __ ] side com sidebar
conversation and dallas man in belman
and dollman
that was the one thing jim lee was uh he
read the first few episodes or yeah i
think he read all the episodes by that
time we're sitting down we're talking
about
talking about stuff and he was totally
cool with everything he was loving it
but he goes what does this mean that bad
mites and the dcu
yeah that's the great part jim he's like
oh god okay
an interdimensional imp that stands
batman it's just the perfect breakdown
of the character
um the uh
in in terms of uh your comic book
geekiness uh you
like i remember when you made the
announcement for suicide squad and it
used the old dc logo the ostrander
logo i was like oh we're into something
special and then you put ostrander
himself into in a cameo in squad and
stuff
um and he was great
wonderful he did he actually like legit
pulled that line off he didn't think he
was he was an actor in his young age he
was an actor he was like a stage actor
in fact john economos is named after his
friend who was like his stage manager i
can't remember what john kind of almost
did but he's a real guy the name is a is
he's a friend of a friend of john
ostranders the ostrander is the gift
that keeps on giving apparently yeah
um but one of the you know some people i
think online were like white dragon he
make that up and it's like no this is
not some deep cuts dc stuff
and and uh he goes back to like squad
like the first five ten issues of squad
i remember there was a reference to that
character is that right yeah i can't
remember exactly when white dragon first
came in but he's a real character and
then you know peacemaker's dad in like
the cupperberg stuff was a nazi uh who
lived in his head and like was very
racist
so i can kind of combine those two
characters into auggie i mean you know
john cena is too too young probably to
have his dad be an actual nazi but uh
but close to modern day
yeah
yeah um it is uh when i saw
in episode four
the cutaway to the
suit
to the white dragon costume which like
in comics is has barely been seen but
like to see in a screen accurate version
made my fanboy heart sore even for
something so hateful i was just like
come on this guy loves this world man it
is more than apparent
that you're treating the dc characters
with as much love and affection as you
treated the marvel characters with with
guardians
what what is your comic book background
how deep does it go oh it's really deep
i mean my my my my youthful uh life was
a hundred percent around comic books i
wanted to be a comic book writer and a
comic book artist that's what i wanted
to do in all my grade school years and
then when i was in high school i mean i
always loved movies i started but i
started making movies and stuff you know
as i was approaching high school so i
had these split loves and was playing
bands and so i really love all sorts
stuff but comic books i'm a huge huge dc
and a marvel fan and always have been i
mean in you know i have my favorite
characters and things that i know more
about than others but i'm a huge fan of
both marvel and dc comics um
you know it's hard not to be if you're
really if you really love comic books
and you read the different ones in fact
kevin you've written some amazing comic
books by the way i don't think i've ever
told you but you're a really yeah but
you're a great great comic book writer
and that's thanks that god's not his
truth
so it's it's uh but there's yeah there's
so much good stuff out there but a lot
of guys who have written for both
companies and it's the same thing you
know it's the writer for me was a writer
it was the artist um and then
secondarily the characters you know but
there are these characters that seem to
have really good luck such such as
daredevil you know
you know and daredevil is gone
especially in like that that period he
went from good great writer to great
writer great but so um it's uh
you know but yeah i love them both
the um
you're handling the material with a plum
uh with somebody who clearly has not
just affection for the genre like i said
you could have delivered
you holding you know two dc action
figures smashing together cursing at
each other and that would have been
like a wonderful show to watch at least
for me right up my alley the fact that
you're making a show that like other
people can get into even if you're not
into the superhero genre like there's a
human
story that's being told at the core of
this insanely funny
and edgy as [ __ ] show
this
show pulls no punches it's probably one
of the least pc things i've seen in the
last 10 years but earns it what by kind
of it's not like going after one group
it seems to be an equal opportunity
offender everybody is under the gun so
to speak
and while you can have fun with
personalities your gift has always been
that you find the humanity in these
people so even in your villains
you give us you you're able to like move
away the muck and show us there is a
person underneath man that's
what keeps bringing me back time and
time again excellent job from one writer
to another oh thanks so much man and
it's like you know i think one of the
things is not thinking of the villains
and villains while i'm writing
although that's hard with auggie smith
but i just think of all these these
they're different opposing forces i mean
somebody brought up to me the other day
because i'm a big fan of annie chang and
lachlan monroe who play fitzgibbon and
song the cops that are on the trail of
peacemaker and i said something about
them the other day and somebody said
yeah but they're kind of like villains
because they're a peacemaker and i'm
like what and somebody said it today
about judo master judo masters of
villain on twitter and i'm like he's a
villain i'm like oh i guess he is to me
he's not i mean he's got his reasons for
doing things and you know and i and
annie and you know i mean sophie song
and
fitzgibbon especially have their reasons
for doing things so i just think of them
as all these opposing forces that have
different desires that move against each
other you know and for the show itself i
don't even really 100 percent think of
it as i think of the superhero costumes
or just the gravy you know because it
really is about you know
you know my version of adrian chase my
version of christopher smith emilia
harcourt you know leo adebayo it's about
those people
and a couple of them happen to wear
these costumes which are kind of
ridiculous really vigilante looks kind
of cool a peacemaker you know he's got
he's got he's a little challenged in the
uh coolness department i can't tell you
how how beautiful i thought his
his sustaining rationale for like
there's not a dove of peace on the gun
man
like how important it was like the the
mythology he built for himself which is
like that's what makes it
okay to do these horrible things that's
some that's some beautiful writing let's
talk about for one of the last things is
uh and it's the thing that seems to have
captured the imagination of people who
haven't even perhaps watched the show
yet is your opening credit sequence you
defeating the skip button by putting
together
one of the most compelling opening
sequences to a tv show since laverne and
shirley for heaven's sake since we
watched them skip down
to shamil shimazu where'd you get the
idea man where where did did you know
early on was it the kind of self
challenge
i mean one of the things that excited me
about doing the show is there's no rules
i mean there's no rules whatsoever they
were gonna let me do whatever uh
you know so i'm like i wanted a dance
sequence i did this i did a movie called
super and i have an animated dance
sequence at the beginning of that that
isn't so different from this version but
in this i had a budget and an ability to
do it live action so i wanted a way to
tell the first of all i did i wanted
people to be able to see the names at
the beginning and not skip over all
those you know you know fred raskin the
editor and greg you know
greg diario and greg featherman are
other editors and uh you know all the
people that work so hard on on the show
and not to be able to skip over their
names
but also to let people know don't don't
think you know what you're saying don't
don't think this is you know another
r-rated superhero show don't think this
is just this don't think it's that
open your mind it can be anything and
there are no rules here let's just go
along for the ride and so that was what
i wanted to get across you know with uh
with the opening credits whole sequences
is brilliant and fun to watch um but for
me the big moment is uh mern and
harcourt come out for some reason that's
the shot that i'm down to they are so
perfect that's the best yep
yeah it's yeah but the whole thing is
absolutely good joy
jen has these great arms and she's uh
and it's also she's an amazing dance so
she's the one person that uh carissa
barton who choreographed that bit uh she
she gave jen
a little bit more to do than some of the
other people because she's she's
actually able to dance you know
john's a little bit more he's got his
you know simple things that he's doing
but it absolutely works and i'm i'm so
fascinated by
why it starts when it starts like five
beats in was that you going like i know
i'm going to end opening cold opening
with the opening chords of that song so
i'm going to leave myself straight
that's right yeah fantastic
it's fun talking to you about this show
because nobody mentions that sort of
stuff i love it it makes me so happy to
see him standing there for the first
like two seconds of music without moving
and at first i was like is that a
creative choice and i was like it has to
be him trying to like
figure out in advance and i love it the
other thing about the
when the ending did you
did you know you were gonna hold on them
for like three seconds so that you see
people being people
it is that is brilliance absolute
brilliance and bliss it's so human man
it make cause first you're sitting there
going that's pretty [ __ ] impressive
but then when you see everybody like
it
it
finds you those characters my favorite
thing about i like i like the olympics
and i like uh ice skating performances
and stuff but there's always that moment
at the end of the ice skating
process
where they're frozen yes
and sometimes they're they're happy
because they just kicked ass and other
times you know they're they're beating
the [ __ ] out of themselves because they
didn't do very well but they got to sit
there with that smile and the out of
breath and that little moment of
humanity it was one of my favorite
things in ice skating what do you think
peacemaker's mom would be like
well i think about it a lot actually i
think a lot about her mom we don't get
it into about his mom we don't get into
his mom on now but listen she can't be
the greatest person in the world if
she's [ __ ] doggy we know that so who
knows
season two um does
uh
does peacemaker remind you of any
character outside the dc universe from
like a book play
show or film can you find a
shakespearean parallel for for chris
well i don't know about a shakespearean
but
one of the things that what's the big
influence on me is do you remember the
red brown captain america tv movie
yes yes so i thought like i saw that as
a kid i thought it was the greatest
thing of all time i thought it was great
so like my memory of the red brown
captain america
is sort of what i was doing i was like
what if that was really [ __ ] up and
raunchy uh that version of captain
america that's what started my
excitement about doing a peacemaker tv
show
that's tremendous man um
if if peacemaker if peacemaker was
assessed by a psychologist
what do you think the diagnosis would be
uh
oh well he definitely has ocd
that's i think for me i have ocd so it's
like that stuff with the dove is is that
is classic
you know can't leave home without it
sort of stuff um
but i think i think that he probably has
we actually get into a little bit of
that you know later on and uh
leota talks about it at some point but
he's definitely got some conspiratorial
paranoid beliefs and um
and uh and i think that makes sense that
he would have some of those you know
sort of paranoid beliefs having his
father in his early structure his early
framework as a child
being that completely untrustable
situation i think would set him up for
that sort of uh
belief pattern as an adult not only that
is bad obviously as a conspiracy
believer so
and you're also you're telling like a
father-son story and you're telling a
low-key
mother-daughter story too as like
as as she has to find out that everybody
regards her mother is this like monster
who has no regard for human life yeah
and i think that's one of the things
that brings them they both have these
parents who couldn't seem more different
like this black powerful woman who's
like amazing at what she does in this
old white racist dude but they're both
really power hungry and uh are both very
powerful people and overbearing on their
children so there are some similarities
for leota with her mother and peacemaker
with his relationship to his father and
i think that that bonds them a little
bit
um their last one they gave me was uh
what do you think the peacemaker would
talk to his therapist about if he had
one
i think that peacemaker if he went to
therapy would probably just go into long
diatribes about the different people
he's had sex with and the kind of sex he
had and i think he would try to stay out
of his feelings as much as possible and
talk about his sexual exploits the guy's
a sexual omnivore and i think that
that's his sort of obsession and uh the
thing he does to uh you know escape from
reality also maybe he might talk about
the history of heavy metal but he gets
into that a little bit further on down
the in the episode
the uh the heavy metal soundtrack is a
jersey kids dream come true jersey kid
who grew up in the 80s uh dream come
true it's fantastic um the the uh
i i can't wait to watch
uh the rest uh i can't wait to see it
more i it feels like
it's something that you could return to
again and again and again i hope i hope
this ain't a one and done thing because
yeah yeah we all want to do that so
we're we're all
john and me and the whole crew we're all
into it so this is the highest
compliment i could possibly pay it i
never watch it and go [ __ ] it should
have been me i watch it and go [ __ ] this
was made for me
like
thanks man it really feels like a show
that like oh my god like had i never
made a thing in life
this would be the show that i put
everything down for it because that's
the show i'm putting everything down for
now it's pitch perfect man i'm
absolutely loving what you did so glad
thank you so much for doing it keep
making that piece keep guarding that
galaxy my friend i will go thank you man
indeed great guy
it seems
that's the case i've never met him i've
always wanted to meet him i feel like i
kind of did talented lovely [ __ ] dude
man and he like you know
we didn't
hit this gong very hard but he was
making a motion picture
or working on a motion picture i don't
know if they're shooting it like a mere
20 minutes before we spoke he's in
atlanta
you know guarding guarding that galaxy
if you will for the third time
um good dude and uh i you know i can't
say enough good things about peacemaker
he's telling a story i never seen told
in this space with these characters with
comic book characters um particularly in
this medium you know maybe in comic
books somebody was clever enough to tell
the story but
he's doing the lord's work that's a
great show check out peacemaker on hbo
max every thursday until they take it
away from you and then hopefully they
bring it back for another season
that's how these things work hopefully
uh that's it for this very special
edition
of fat man beyond man i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith we offer you
a jeff's kiss
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
ten year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old up kevin smith